what would you do if you could assemble
your very own Avengers initiative better
yes what would Jason Mewes do best known
as J of Jay and Silent Bob Fame news sat
down with us while promoting his new
movie madness and the method which he
both stars in and directed now that
muses a full-fledged filmmaker who's
been in charge of his own production we
decided to step things up a notch and
ask him what he'd do with more
magnificent responsibilities to be
specific we asked a lifelong comic book
found what he would do if he were in the
Nick Fury role and had the opportunity
to recruit his own team of Avengers from
Marvel Comics vast pool of characters
and we were just talking about good guys
either villain switch sides and comics
all the time sometimes for weird reasons
why wouldn't they do the same for a
foul-mouthed stoner from New Jersey
who's bold enough to wield of pong saber
and brave enough to unload a machine gun
at an iron killable angel for one Muse
has been a comic book fan all his life
and affinity has been reflected in Kevin
Smith's movies and the characters they
play in them that drug addled duo has
appeared in both Smurfs movies and
real-life comics as a superhero alter
egos Bluntman and chronic
they've also met and worked with Marvel
Comics icon Stan Lee on multiple
occasions with Lee having a cameo in
Smith's Mallrats
and another cameo decades later amused
madness and the method but these aren't
just had tips to the nerd crowd we use
has an enthusiasm for comic books it's
downright infectious and as an actor
he's even made appearances in the CW's
our reverse get some free comics read
them comics love and slip to comics so
now that you know his bona fides the
question remains what would Jason Mewes
team of Avengers look like though the
event just rust to has grown post
endgame to include what feels like
hundreds of people from all over the
universe including sorcerers as
guardians and even Howard the Duck the
first Avengers movie showed the promise
of the shared Marvel Universe was just
six heroes so walk over sex like many
words mu started off its election with
three major powerhouses the Incredible
Hulk
the adamantium infused mutant Wolverine
and he immensely overpowered spider-man
but after that things got interesting
- spittin it could be villains - right
Muse indeed went for the villains but
didn't waste time with a lower-level
likes of crossbones a bull's-eye
awesome New York City bank robbers he
went straight for the gods here so
should we say Thanos
apocalypse with three slots to go news
pick both instantly making his team one
of the most formidable forces of
destruction in the entire universe not
very heroic maybe but hey they'll get
the job done at least so longus has
someone a little more level-headed in
charge it takes more than pure power to
make a good team if only to give great
motivational speeches every would-be
band of superhero needs a leader and
know neither blunt man nor chronic are
up for the picking you need a team
leader beside right uh Jeff Flake your
most kneecap like Iron Man or Captain
America or you know what
Cyclops poaching the frequent leader of
the x-men is a bold move and it inspired
me to make some other changes to his
roster before locking it in I love
spider-man but I faked I was just
thinking about magneto I mean the
powerhouses I feel like I'm Isaac too
powerful but but I think it would be
pretty crazy and great well handed to
him Magneto's subbing in for spider-man
to stand alongside apocalypse Wolverine
and Cyclops it's pretty great even if
it's not as crazy as imagining
spider-man and fan esteeming up
especially after what happened in the
movies Muse ended up sending spider-man
to the curb instead settling on Cyclops
as a leader of the team with that he
locked in his own personal squad of New
Jersey Avengers
so we already of the hawk and then we
have Thanos apocalypse magneto Cyclops
is the leader and Wolverine so that's
six I believe but a team half made up of
heroes and half of slightly less heroic
figures Jason Mewes assembled a strange
configuration of Avengers heavy on the
x-men and the heavy hitters it's the
kind of squad that makes you wonder how
the team would really work together
Thanos apocalypse or Magneto turning
face to plain ice for the good guys is
something that makes sense
on an individual basis but imagining or
three of them working together for a
common cause without infighting that's a
little harder to figure we don't care
how cool it is news team wouldn't last
six issues before they all try to kill
each other
despite that potential problem Mew
shared only one regret about the
constitution of a Super Hero Squad the
fact that he didn't have any room on
there for someone who runs really really
fast
I should add speedster I mean again it's
tough because there's like Quicksilver
would be awesome
but I'm gonna stick with that there's
- on top of checking out his directorial
debut madness and the method you can
catch Jason Mewes in the upcoming film
at Jay and Silent Bob a reboot touring
the United States in a roadshow format
starting October 15th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos by your favorite
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]